avancer s'il vous plaît c'est dans cette
cellule du château de Joux qui est mort
tout saint l'ouverture le 7 avril 1803
esclave affranchi devenu gouverneur de
Saint Domingue il est un symbole de la
lutte contre l'esclavage et pour les
droits des Noirs chaque année et le
locaux représentant de l'État et membre
de la diaspora haïtienne lui rendre
hommage cet artiste installé à Paris
assisté au commémorations pour la
première fois et c'était émouvant d'être
là là où la laisser sa vie là où là
vécu beaucoup de souffrance et de la
nostalgie aussi parce que il était loin
moi je suis loin d'Haïti tout en étant
libre tout en étant écrivain je sais que
souvent intimement j'imagine lui dans un
cachot où il fait froid
et il devait être mort avant de trouver
la mort plusieurs associations
françaises et suisses avaient fait le
déplacement pour ce 220e anniversaire
c'est une façon pour dire
nous aussi non seulement les Haïtiens
les noirs
nous venons ici
qu'il ne faut jamais oublier tout ça
l'ouverture c'est notre héros et il faut
s'en rappeler c'est un combat contre le
racisme qui a pu être mené à partir
c'est lui le commencement
et
nous sommes la continuation une
cérémonie achevée en musique avec cette
hymne à la liberté interprété par les
élèves du conservatoire de Pontarlier
[Musique]